hey everybody it's Mike from order flows
and welcome back to my channel it's uh
Labor Day weekend here in the US and
it's Sunday night I'm recording this
video it's about 6 30 p.m and uh be
quite honest if you're trying to trade
this Market over Labor Day weekend don't
just uh turn off your computer or
something you can have them on and you
know sort of do your back testing but
you know Labor Day weekend is one of
those uh weekends it's time to enjoy
um life you know life doesn't
necessarily always revolve around
markets I'm a big believer that Traders
should have a good uh
trading Market life versus uh family
life you know you got to have an
interest outside of the markets and
before we jump in if you've been
enjoying these videos be sure to
subscribe to the channel click the
notification Bell so you don't miss any
new uploads and if you find today's
video helpful hit the like button for me
and leave a comment sharing your biggest
takeaway I love hearing your feedback
and you know it's your feedback that
gives me ideas for new videos so your
sport really does go a long way in
helping me create more great videos just
like this so let's go ahead and talk
about today's uh topic now this is
something that a lot of people have been
asking me to do a video on it's the
order flows ratios and this is a way
that I've analyzed order flow for a long
time and you know when I first released
the order flows Trader software this is
what uh you know one of the original
tools that I had in there because I was
doing this mostly in my head or with a
calculator for some of the bigger
numbers and what order flow ratio is
it's a measurement of the order flow in
a bar in certain areas okay because
remember what a market exists to do
doesn't exist for people to trade to
speculate really you know that that's
one of the purposes but really it was
the Futures markets were created so that
producers could hedge their risk right
they could sell out you know you know
when we talk about you know Futures
Trading now you know it's mostly
um
you know stock indices and bonds but you
know the original Futures contracts were
agricultural contracts you know this the
Japanese supposedly invented the Futures
contracts with rice you know so that
people can uh you know sort of buy their
rice now for future delivery and you
know it's it that's still the main core
of a lot of Futures contracts
uh to this day so
when a market is trading right think of
it don't think you know a lot of Traders
now right that are sort of led to
believe that oh you know everyone is
buying because they're speculating no
you know a lot of markets exist
specifically for participants to trade
you know for example when you start
getting into the Commodities you know
people that trade a lot of the commodity
markets have to for a reason because
they either are producing it or they
need it to manufacture stuff right you
know like
um you know like Cuomo it was a big
contract in Asia you know and it's it's
traded because it's used by a lot of
Industries you know it's used in cooking
oil it's used in soaps shampoos all
sorts of things right obviously the
metals copper
um you know gold silver
um obviously the grain contracts okay
so don't necessarily think that you know
everything that you see go through is
pure speculation right so like in in the
contract such as you know well this is
soy meal this is not a footprint chart
but let me just go back here switch it
back on uh you know for example wheat
okay
right a lot of the trading that you see
in there is done by people that need you
know maybe they're they're making uh red
products right or they're making pastas
you know a lot of the big pasta makers
they're very active in wheat you know
General Mills
um those companies
and the order flows ratios right is a
way that I've used order flow to decide
whether they're sort of stopping volume
in a bar or if there's
sort of price rejection okay and in the
order flows Trader software this was
again one of the original tools that was
in there and it was just a way to
highlight on a chart to me me personally
because you know when I first started
with the software it wasn't developed I
didn't sit down and say I'm going to
make a software and start selling it you
know I was trading order flow
specifically
I met with the programmer and I said hey
this is how I look at order flow and
this is you know the order flows ratios
was one of those things I said can you
put that on a footprint chart just to
highlight to me so I don't have to sit
here and say you know what is this a 95
or is this a 0.76 is this a 0.88 it
would just highlight it to me and if it
was within a certain threshold right it
would color it red color if it was a red
down bar
blue color if it's green up bar
and it was just the normal order flow
that's going through
right just the market facilitating its
trade
it would just color it black
right that's why you see black numbers
above bars and Below bars that's why you
see red numbers above red candles or
blue numbers
um
below green up candles okay and again
calculation
you know some people think it's like a
big secret it's not right you could look
at a bar you could sort of figure it out
okay
1.31 what is it it's the the top volumes
up here 13 into 17 gives you a ratio of
1.31 95 1 into 95.
24 38 into 9 or so uh you know the other
way around but
when it's blue
it's telling me you know what if it's no
let me take a step back there's two
types of ratios there's a ratio balance
High there's a ratio bounds low
ratio balance High
indicates
price rejection
ratio bounds low indicates price support
so just really quick let me just find it
here in the settings order closed ratio
right you want to enable it
now these numbers are not set in stone
some people have taken these ratios and
put them in their software some people
even call these things like The Secret
order flow algo it's not a secret right
it's not something hidden in the tea
leaves or anything you're just doing
Simple Math at the edge of a bar because
at the top of a red candle you want to
be paying attention to how the Market's
reacting at the top of a red candle
then obviously
look you're at the top of this red
candle here right here see 108 82 1813.
why do you want to focus up here at the
top of a red candle because obviously
the market traded up there stopped and
reversed basically you're looking at it
from a reversal point in the bar just as
in a green up candle you want to be
focusing on the bottom bid side because
the market in this case well this bar
opened up here closed up here so you're
watching it from this reversal point
just as in this green candle this one's
got a wick these other ones didn't but
this bar opened up traded down I'm
curious was there anything interesting
happening in the order flow down here no
it's a ratio of one it's just sort of
your normal order flow okay and then the
market you know we close back up here
fine it doesn't matter to me
but
these ratios again there's two ratios
ratio bonds High ratio bonds low
right ratio bonds high is price
exhaustion ratio bonds low is price
defense now
I know people
sometimes get these two mixed up but
really all it is is a ratio 30 and above
now you could adjust it right I used to
use 25 over the years I've expanded it
out to 30. ratio bonds low price defense
0.69 now this is where it gets freaking
funny because it's actually my ratio is
actually 0.7 the reason I have it at
0.69 is is there's not much difference
between 0.7 and 0.69 but I've seen
people literally copy that ratio put it
on their software exactly as that and
another reason I I used to actually use
one but
you know I just find it interesting that
they use the exact same ratio they got
no imagination whatsoever you know to
sort of make it their own fine whatever
you know give me some credit for it at
least if you're stealing my stuff but uh
you know for me as far as I'm concerned
hey you know what order flow is free to
everybody in the sense that you know if
you get software that can plot it and
find you know it said it's not a big
secret on how it's calculated even
though some people would lead you to
believe that really the way reason I
have it on my chart is because
when I'm
getting I remember what I just said okay
I'm getting ahead of myself
I'm looking at let me just find a good
example okay well it's a wheat that's a
eight range chart I don't actually use
an eight range chart let's go back to uh
e-mini's here yes okay on an eight range
chart which is one of the types of
charts that I like to look at now
remember okay what I was saying about
looking at
on a red I'm sorry on a green up candle
right I'm why am I interested on the
bottom mid side of a green up candle
because
the market traded down and started to
reverse that's a potential reversal okay
because I'm always looking for areas
where the market can reverse now here we
are at the low of the day I've got a
bullish ratio 48 it's blue color so what
that means again I'm not so focused on
the actual number in the ratio as
opposed to it just being blue color
because what that's telling me is that
it's above 30. your ratio bonds high is
going to be 30 and above a ratio bounds
low is going to be 0.69
to zero it can't be and ratio cannot be
negative okay
so if I'm at a potential reversal Point
obviously the low of the day that's what
this red line is the low of the day
and I see a bullish ratio coming in
right meaning a green candle with a
ratio that's blue
to me that's a good trade setup now I
like to use it with order flows
Divergence meaning a new or equal low
and positive Delta so here right this
gold color here I know is I got a
um
order flow Divergence as well as a
bullish ratio to me those are you know
bread and butter almost automatic trades
as long as the next bar starts to start
trade a bit higher all right and you can
see right off this low we rallied from
you know the the 09 area all the way up
to 18 pulled back to 12 even went higher
it's not just when you're looking at
these ratios right it's not just about
saying oh I got a bullish ratio or
bearish ratio a blue number here that
must mean something no really the way
you want to use it the way
that
and this is what it gets back to you
know other softwares putting it in their
software is just sort of a tool but they
don't teach you how to use it you know
just like you open up ninja Trader right
there's hundreds if not thousands
probably thousands of indicators in here
they don't teach you how to use them
right figure it out yourself right and
even the people that copy the Oracle is
Trader software this tool they don't
teach you how to use because they didn't
develop it right I've used this in my
trading for a very long time so it's not
just about saying you know let's find an
example here right like oh here's a
bearish ratio gotta get short or here's
a bullish ratio you got to get long you
gotta put it in context right the whole
point of it is a is a potential reversal
signal so for taking a trade right you
want to have it coming in at a swing
High here
right or you know if there's a
one in here
no near me is this a swing low I don't
know you know but just went sideways on
you
um
you know even in the night session right
seven in the morning here
high of the day
bearish ratio
right
that's when the number came out but um
yeah you know high of the day bearish
ratio
okay so here's a bullish ratio on the
low of the day okay it failed right this
is not a 100 guarantee that the Market's
going to go up but it's giving me a sign
of potential reversal
okay I'm fine to to take this trade here
and
book a small loss because when I get
you know the trade like that happened on
Friday on the low of the day
right here
I know that it can give me a nice trade
so again you know at the end of the day
it's not just about seeing a bullish
ratio oh there's a bullish ratio I gotta
get long no that's not how you should be
using it it's not how I used it I mean I
don't know I mean the one thing is you
know maybe people have taken it and sort
of developed some sort of training
strategy off of it but
you know as the person that first
started using it that developed it and
put it on software for people to look at
that's not the intention even though it
will show up on every single bar
um you know that that's not necessarily
the way you should use it now if you're
in a trade okay you know if I'm getting
long from down here for another reason
and I see a bullish ratio coming in
they sort of helps me want to stay in
the trade longer but I wouldn't
necessarily be getting long off of a
bullish ratio in the middle of a move
now I've seen some people say oh you got
two bullish or bearish you know too
bullish or too bearish in this case two
bearish ratios in a row that must mean
something I should get short
okay whatever
um
I don't know it's just one of those
things where
you know like candlesticks sometimes
they work sometimes they don't work
that's up to you if you want to do that
but
um
There Was You Know back in the day
I did sort of
you know maybe if I go into a four range
chart
um
it's sort of the say developed a
potential system but you know just sort
of looking at like two in a row I used
to call it the three in a row The Three
Musketeers the three blind mice it would
basically be if you had three bullish
ratios in a row or three bearish ratios
let's see if I could find one here
one here's yeah one two three in a row
you'd often find yourself getting a
pullback you know this on a four range
chart because you're going to get
there's a higher chance of getting three
in a row
um on a shorter range chart like in this
case a four range chart you're also
going to get a pullback within the two
bars right of the second and third so
first bullish ratio second bullish ratio
third bullish ratio you finally get this
pull back right in between of the uh
second and third bar and sort of pop
back up it was just an area if you're
looking to buy I just found that when
you do have three in a row
you'll often do get a pullback into the
second and third
bars in the three ratios in a row
okay
let's see if there's any others on
Friday
two in a row
here is one here but then you got that
red bar in the middle
uh uh just really quick
there's one two three you get this pull
back in between these two
does it go higher yeah a little bit but
again if you're trading pullbacks right
you're getting a little bit better entry
so you can have a tight stop you know
for a smaller win I guess
but that's you know it was one that I
had
tested for a while a few years ago but
I sort of moved on to different things
so anyway I hope that sort of clears up
how to use the ratios ideally that's how
I use them and when I've developed them
you know again I used to just sit here
with the calculator like I could sort of
see this I could do that simple math in
my head 50 into 120 I know it's about
two so that's not going to be a ratio 64
and 273 is about four it's not going to
be a ratio
um you know I would just need a
calculator for some of the you know a
little bit more
closer numbers you know if it was going
to come in around 26 or 27 or something
like that now just really quick
um let me get
uh with my bond chart here so
this is bonds but I'll tell you what
I'll make it
10 years I'll go back to a full range
chart here
and I've got the ratios off on this one
so I'll turn the ratios back on
and just really quick I because I do
this is a question that does come up
um
bigger the number the bigger the ratio
like this is 270 is that more important
than you know 26 or 226 no you know 157
is that stronger than
you know
we got anything else in here like for
example
56 versus you know 158 is the 158
stronger I see a bigger move here no all
it's a ratio so all I'm really concerned
with
is as long as it's over the threshold
that's all I'm concerned with okay so
whether it's 56 or 158 I treat them the
same now the difference between racial
balance High ratio bonds low
as far as there being a bullish or
bearish ratio again I would treat them
the same so even though this is a ratio
bonds High indicating pricing rejection
this .12 indicates price you know
stopping volume
I would the fact that there's bearish
ratio here is again telling me there's a
potential reversal taking place just as
here is telling me as a potential
reversal taking place okay
so again I'm not so I'm not caught up in
the magnitude of the ratio all I'm
concerned with is if it meets the
minimum requirement to give me a bullish
or bearish ratio
all right so that wraps up this video on
ratios I hope that clears things up once
and for all for a lot of you guys again
I used to calculate these you know in my
head and they said for the closer ones I
would just use a calculator I mean a lot
of them you could do in your head
honestly
um
you know you don't necessarily need a
calculator for it but again it's like
the the sort of the borderline numbers
you know if it was going to come in
around 24 or 28 you know sometimes you
don't want to think you know like here
uh it's 23 and 566 what is that you know
well it's 24.61 okay it's not that
um for me to uh be concerned with so
that's why you see ratios on order flow
charts nowadays
um especially my charts obviously I
spent a lot of time with them and you
know and again the difference between my
order flow is Trader chart and
you know other charts out there that do
have it is you know being the one that
initiated it so to speak
I'm the one that teaches Traders how to
use it as opposed to oh we have it in
our software figure it out how to use it
you know blind leading the blind so to
speak so
again I'm not trying to knock other
Traders
um that have developed their own ways
around ratios more power to you but I'm
just sharing with you
how I develop them how I use them and if
you want to add them into your trading
great you want to throw stones at me
saying ah this is all you know
ratios don't matter fine that's what
makes up the market right some people
like to use fibs okay you know if
everyone agreed on the markets you know
where it should go everything Marcus
wouldn't move
okay but that's what makes the markets
the markets so anyway guys have a great
video I'm kind of done with my rant in
my explanation so have a great uh rest
of your Memorial uh Labor Day weekend
rather and uh again
don't try to trade this Market until the
market reopens you know Monday we just
had non-farm payrolls on Friday and uh
just wait till Tuesday to start getting
involved in the market so have a great
week everybody and I'll catch you guys
on the next video bye bye